Hi everyone.
Mister Brazil directly from Barra in Rio de Janeiro.
Barra is the place that's going to host...
...most of the events, sports competitions for the Rio 2016 Summer Games.
You're going to find brand new facilities: gymnastics, volleyball, basketball areas.
We come first to check if everything is ready for you...
...to make sure whenever you arrive in Brazil, you only think about having fun,...
...get your beer, your coconut water...
...or tie your Brazilian bikini or Speedo, but just enjoy Rio de Janeiro because...
...people think that you come in to Rio not just for the Olympic Games...
...but for the party, carnival.
It's just that Brazilian laid-back and happy way of life.